this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am
ramsay personality rachel cruz and for
the first time in history
my
my co-pilot
is dave ramsey
[Music]
about five minutes before the show
started i was like what if you let me
take the lead just for an hour of the
show
well you're in here because that has not
happened yet with a ramsey personality
where dave is in the is in the coho seat
how you feeling over there uh i'm it's
kind of like when i was teaching you to
drive
bracing i was teaching
i'm trying to not touch the brake on the
passenger side while you're supposed to
be braking at the red light yeah
right before we went live i was like and
which buttons do i push to get the
callers in that's real that's real
comforting right there oh man well it's
gonna be a fun hour so it's a free call
anywhere in america triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we'll
start off with myra in lubbock texas
myra welcome to the show
hello rachel hello dave i love your show
by the way rachel
oh thank you
yes
um quick backstory before my question is
i started working part-time
at a
advisor's office and it's been great the
person that was full-time was off for
medical leave
and
she got better and now she's doing
part-time and so we're working together
and things like that but prior to that
it was other people helping in the
office that were just interns and so
from the beginning you know i was having
to pick up from where they left off to
what they knew and because she she had
to leave um unexpectedly um to do her
medical leave
and so point is i just i i just picked
up where everybody left off and i was
doing my best trying my best and things
like that but now that she's come back
it's been very difficult because she
could be
very aggressive with her words and
um she
doesn't use that the tone of voices she
uses with me um well she changes her
tone of voice when the financial advisor
is not around and she said things to me
in the past like i'm the full time don't
touch my themes on my desk um and it's
just little petty things you know like
i don't want my your lotion on my desk
um don't move my
okay my paper clips and things like that
and
my question is how do
how do i go on if i feel that it's just
it takes so much energy because when i'm
in the office i'm always trying to not
do something that's going to take her
off or she's going to be passive
aggressive again or she's going to be
rude to me yeah
and there is locations and work
together sure and she's so draining sure
absolutely so myra why did she leave in
the first place what you said medical
leave
yeah so her cancer came back and
thankfully she was
she was able to take care of it
and now her doctor is asking her to not
be full-time so that she can't you know
slowly back into it yeah um she is older
and you know she has like no filter and
things like that which
i i'm young and i am not have you i wish
i was myra have you have you confronted
her at all have you sat down
um and confronts you know that's kind of
a strong word but have you asked
questions to her of hey do you realize
kind of how you're coming off is
everything okay how are you doing
because because we find here you know at
ramsay we have you know almost 1200
uh team members so working on
interpersonal relationship with
something i feel like we do on a daily
basis and usually you find
that people who are hurting can tend to
hurt people right that's saying hurt
people hurt people so there's a part of
me thinks that she's there's probably a
level of her that's stressed freaked out
fearful of her own story and kind of
what's going on and it's coming out on
you which is not okay but if you have
you talked to her about it at all
um i i've not said it the way you said
it and i think the way you
you're asking me to approach it makes
sense um i have talked to the fa and i
have told him the situation and he's
told me you know she's really hard to
work with and other people have told me
you know just
she's she's a little territorial and
things like that and so it never gave me
the impression that she was
she was acting this way because of the
current situation it just it's giving me
more of the impression that that's just
the way she is and this lady
this lady's scared
and she's been scared a long time
and um and all this crap is to cover
over her fear
she's afraid for a job she's afraid for
her health
uh you're
she sees you as a threat
and so uh the good news is you're just a
sweet lady and i think if you'll just
look at her as someone who's scared
uh kind of uh put a little different
picture when you see her instead of the
big old mean lady that's rough and tough
and hard to work with instead look at
her as a a little child who's afraid and
how would you treat someone that was
afraid
with pity and with kindness and you
you'd help them and you'd how can i
serve you and what can i do for you
and she'll calm down eventually and if
she doesn't
it's just a part-time job go get another
one it's not worth working with jerks
that's the other thing so i mean leave
it ain't that big a deal uh but you
don't don't in other words don't let
yourself be subjected to a toxic
situation because you don't because you
refuse to walk out the door on a
part-time job so just say saytonata out
of here baby done but if you want to try
to work on the personal idea of it which
is why you call
i think you just treat her with
unbelievable levels of kindness and just
because i i'll guarantee you this lady's
really afraid
she's afraid for her job she thinks
you're gonna they're gonna kick her out
because she was hard to work with before
and then she had a cancer problem so
she's unreliable and you know she's
afraid they're gonna put her on the
street and you're gonna take her job if
you look too good so how can i help you
you've been through so much
uh man i just want to support you you're
kind of a legend around here because she
is
legend maybe you're not the way you want
to be a legend but she's kind of a
legend a true statement nonetheless
but i wonder too even after you know how
work how the workplace has changed so
much since kovid
dealing with people now via technology
there's not that that in-person
connection is as much anymore within
companies i mean obviously meyer sounds
like it is for you but you talk about
this a lot in entre leadership though
that
of how to deal with these situations
that it's not going around obviously and
talking
and bashing her to other people so the
fact you went up myra was good to your
leader i think was a smart move but also
to have the ability to sit down with
someone that you work with especially if
it's a for a long period of time you
guys have history and it sounds like you
guys are pretty hand in hand with what
you do
um
getting that it's it is key because it's
exhausting like if you go to work and
you don't like the person you're with
all the time that's the reason the dread
works so it's a reason
i would i would give it a couple weeks
of just killing her with kindness and if
that if you can't get anywhere and if
you continue to have just an abusive
situation i would just go leave
just go get another job
uh it's not worth it yeah and uh i mean
you talked to leadership and their
answer was a lame-o horrible answer from
leadership well she's always kind of
been that way which means we're scared
of her too
oh my god you know so we don't have
anybody like that that i answer that
about you know
we you get to work somewhere else if
you're going to be a bud around here so
we don't do that but um i mean you can
have a bad day you have a bad week but
you don't get to just have the
reputation of being
hard to work with the grouch
that's silly this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality rachel cruz along
with my co-host the man himself dave
ramsey
all right we're gonna go to dave in
grand rapids hey dave welcome to the
show
hi hi how are you doing great how can we
help
okay so i guess i'll start out uh maybe
different i have every one of your book
states i've read them all i had your
tapes educated both my children who are
30 and 33
on your logic of how to
you know stay stay healthy stay safe go
fall into the pitfalls and i've also led
that in my wife and our lifestyle good
well i followed all the steps right i
have a mortgage that we paid off on our
home last year wow
i'm 65 my wife is 62.
she took her first social security check
last week i had her retire after 40
years of work uh she just didn't want to
do it anymore so i said that's it you're
done
so we did that i have about 600 000 in
a 401ks
65 as i said don't plan on retiring uh
love work
sales engineer for a company just love
work and for health
reasons continue you know
working your mind
life insurance i mean health insurance i
don't fall into that category so i get
health insurance by working but the
question i have today that i don't find
in your book
i went to a class on how to save taxes
and money just a class that was taught
at a local school
and the thing he said is your 401k you
should start doing a roth conversion
now
so you're taking the money in my 401k
which are not lost
and transferring that over before you
get to 72 and
that would be a good thing to do
and i'm gonna turn it over to you
well um
the tax bracket i've been would be 22
yeah probably and i have room to do that
but the benefit the benefit of it all
being in roth is if you're going to
leave it alone it's going to continue to
grow tax-free
and you can leave it in there growing
tax-free where if you don't you've got
to begin the required minimum
distributions the rmds is 72 and a half
like you like the person told you that
is correct information so you're going
to have to begin drawing down on it if
it's in a traditional at 72 and a half
whether you want to or not you're going
to pay the taxes on a little portion
every year okay because the irs wants
their money so uh if instead you have
moved it to a roth by then
um all at once or a little bit at a time
over five years or whatever uh you've
already paid all your taxes at that
point
and it will grow tax-free from then on
if you're going to turn right around and
pull it back out
within a few months or a few years then
that doesn't do any good if you're
probably not really touching the money
it'll probably make sense to do that
because you probably got another 20
years before the money's ever accessed
really then like to 85
okay
right or 95 or whatever you live to
right right yeah right my dad's 90. yeah
so uh
again the faster you're going to use
that money up
the worse the idea is to move it to a
roth and i think what i'm hearing you
say is you guys are in really good shape
and you probably don't need to access
this money ever
no no credit card uh you know paid the
cars off you're still working
yeah
yeah still working uh so but basically
if we take 600 and we pay taxes on it it
looks a lot like 400.
right
and uh you know and so but it's gonna
look like that anyway when you pull it
out out of a traditional later on so
you're you're gonna get the hit sometime
in the next decade
one way or the other yeah so you might
as well put it in there and let it grow
tax-free because i think you're going to
be leaving it alone
it's good because when you start to
transfer it that's you have to have you
have to have the ability to have
the cash though to pay those taxes well
if you got that then that's even better
but in his case he would just use some
of the money to pay the taxes yeah he
would reduce the balance from 600 down
to the you know he's going to give up
200 000 now or give it up later the
downside is is you don't have the 200
000 of
going to taxes growing from now on
through it yes exactly until you have to
pull it out but you got the required
minimum distributions beginning at 78
two and a half used to be 70 and a half
now anyway
so i probably i don't think that's a bad
suggestion
it's it's a weird suggestion because you
don't hear that from the financial
community very often why but um
because they've been anti-raw don't do a
roth if you're over 55 because it
doesn't have time to grow okay and so uh
by and large and but i'm 61 i'm not
touching mine i moved everything into
roth years ago and i put everything into
roth now which is the same thing really
like our 401k here at the office i dump
all mine into a roth 401k and i pay the
taxes and move the match over into roth
at the end of every year
uh so
and do roth personally so um you know
all that so
because i'm never going to touch that
money yeah that money will be going to
the to the kids i mean it's not gonna uh
because i won't need it i've got other
sources of income it's good all right up
next is sam from tampa hey sam welcome
to the show
hey thank you guys very much for taking
my call
so i have a question in regards to whole
life insurance
insurance
and i've been listening to the show for
several years now i'm a big fan and dave
i know your opinion
on our whole life versus term uh however
i recently got married uh nine months
ago
and my wife
she's 27 years old
her grandparents purchased a whole life
insurance policy for her when she was
born so they've been paying off it for
27 years now
and essentially
her grandparents are transferring it to
me and so i can either
surrender it now and get a basically
about five thousand dollars
or i can continue to pay in about
eighteen dollars a month um and you know
get the i think it's uh forty thousand
dollars worth of life insurance coverage
and it's a savings type uh account where
it uh accumulates and we can surrender
at any time so
um i i know i would never buy a whole
life uh insurance policy based on your
guidance i would only get the term
however
in this case i'm you know getting it's
been transferred to me so i'm trying to
find out uh you know what your advice is
on this yeah that's a great question sam
so
i i would actually my husband we had
kind of a similar
situation from other family
um members kind of thing
and kind of exactly basically the same
thing had a policy um for us as well and
we immediately just cashed it out and
opened a mutual fund and put that money
in there because it's going to grow
so much more the growth is going to be
insane especially since you guys are so
young um in something like a mutual fund
versus sitting in that whole life
account and then you guys just go get
term insurance um for you and your wife
and so you're keeping your investments
and your savings separate from your
insurance but i would
um i would circle back are her are her
grandparents still living
her grand parents are still living and i
just haven't gotten a chance to talk to
the financial advisor to get the details
on it no
you don't need to have a discussion but
it's not a financial advisor it's a it's
an insurance agent but i would financial
advisors don't sell this crap
but i would wrap around to the
grandparents though and just out of just
i think honoring them and what they've
done because their heart in it was
really good for her right hey we're
gonna set this up for you
and all of that and just wrap back
around and say hey you know
the gratitude that you guys have that
you know you got five thousand dollars
and that's amazing and how thankful you
are but hey here's our plan going
forward just so you're aware
we're going to get you know our life
insurance over here and we're actually
going to put this in an investment we're
really excited about it because we hope
to use it for a down payment on a home
down the road or whatever it is but at
least giving them that dignity dignity
and honor
um
of letting them know what you're doing
with it because i think that that's i
mean it's a gift a huge gift which is
very kind yeah
if you want to go depending on how
touchy this is with the with the
grandparents you could sit down with a
smartvestor pro and open a roth ira
and just put the money into the roth
into good mutual funds and then you can
show grandpa hey grandpa this y'all get
a great thing for her thank you so much
or she could say this even better than
you seeing it and we met with our
financial advisor and we decided to put
it in into an investment and so we moved
it over to there but boy you gave us a
great jump start on there and here's
what this mutual fund's done for the
last 70 years it's averaged you know
11.2 percent for the last 70 years it's
really exciting and you can show that
you didn't go to vegas with the money or
buy a lotto ticket which is your grand
or grandfather's fear that you're an
idiot right and so you just kind of got
to prove that you had a plan
and the more she says grandpa thank you
for this and we talked about it and we
met with our financial advisor you don't
need financial advice from their
financial advisor because they're not a
real financial advisor real financial
advisors don't sell cash value insurance
only insurance people sell them
financial advisors only believe in term
this is the ramsey show
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
live on the debt free stage here at the
headquarters of ramsey solutions is ryan
and michaela hey you guys welcome in hey
guys hey how's it going good well you're
standing on the stage for a reason right
that's right
your journey is you've become debt free
excited incredible incredible you guys
congratulations so where are you guys
from we're from knoxville tennessee nice
go vols
what part
um west side nice okay my husband grew
up in the bearden area
did you go to farragut uh no i actually
grew up in morristown oh okay
knoxville's awesome that's so great all
right how much debt did you guys pay off
so we paid off 193 thousand dollars in
32
months my gosh we did amazing in 36
months 32 months 32 months and how um oh
my gosh okay so what kind of income were
you guys making during that time uh we
started about 107 and ended about 170 at
170 so you got a big jump that's awesome
uh and what do you guys do for a living
so i'm a teacher and i'm a pharmacist in
your pharmacist and what kind of debt
was the 193
000 uh 19 was a car and the rest was
student loans whoa
where'd you go to school ut
i also went to ut
yeah we both did so okay but pharmacists
yes yeah so that the pharmacy school
bills were were it that was the bulk of
it for sure so when did you guys
graduate so i graduated uh may of 19.
okay and i graduated in 2021 okay whoa
just the other day so yeah just the
other day yeah so part of this was we
actually cash flowed her master's degree
so we're wow super excited about that
too amazing you guys how long have you
guys been married a little over two
years now okay
so 36 months ago or 32 months ago i'm
sorry
what what started this journey for you
guys because this is huge people keep
this kind of debt around especially
student loans for
decades so it was my last year of
pharmacy school
and i had just gotten my job offer from
where i was going to start after i
graduated and all i could see was dollar
signs right new car new house new
clothes everything and i'll never forget
she turned and looked at me and said
don't you have a bunch of student loans
to pay off i'm like nah babe i'll just
pay them for 20 years and they'll be
forgiven be perfect
and
luckily later that week i had the wisdom
to start
looking and i realized that i had no
idea how to manage money so it's my
first job actually making real money
and so i came across a familiar face we
actually used y'all's curriculum in
pharmacy school we had a personal
finance class oh wow so
kind of revisited those um
those aspects principles and just took
off with it drank the kool-aid like you
might say so
went right in never looked back very
cool very cool so uh
michaela you you're like okay you got
some student loans and he comes back
with a plan
yeah so it was definitely you know you
see that money and it's like yeah we
want a house right now and just put this
into perspective for the past 32 months
we've been living in a one bedroom
apartment
just us and we've had all this income
but it's been going to debt so we've
definitely made those sacrifices and
we've i mean when we say one bedroom
it's like a small one bedroom and so
to like see all of our friends getting
houses and starting to have families and
all these things and we're like you know
we're really dedicated to this we're
going to get out of debt and we chunked
at it and we cash flow my masters and we
made some mistakes along the way but we
definitely it was worth every every
minute that's incredible because again
like you said a lot of people kind of
jump in and when you get the big
paycheck and you're like dang we can do
a lot of fun stuff but that less than
three years of sacrifice now yes has
completely freed you guys up okay so
with um what did what would you say the
key of getting out of debt is when
people are asking because they're
hearing these numbers which are just
insane i think we each have like kind of
our difference so like there's always
the free spirit and someone who's more
like tight i would definitely say i'm
more of the free spirit even though it
was my idea i think for me it was
definitely like communication and like
having that visual so i'm a teacher so
obviously like need that visual piece
and so we had like a thermometer and we
like colored it in
different color you know we got i was
like what grade do you teach so i was
teaching third grade yeah
[Music]
yep
so um definitely have that visual piece
and he picked out the color and i got to
color it in and it was just a really it
was a huge team ever but the
communication piece for sure yeah for me
it was all about being content with what
we have so rachel i read your book love
your life not theirs and that was super
helpful for me because like she alluded
to you know we were seeing all of our
friends get houses you know all this
stuff and it was about really
being thankful for for what we had
during this time and knowing that later
we can you know make those strides to
get the house and your car those sorts
of things so yeah it really helped me so
live like no one else and later you can
live and give like no one else that's
right
ten years from now no one will remember
the one bedroom apartment that's right i
think we'll always remember it you will
no one else will no one else will you're
the only ones that'll remember it i
remember all those places we live but uh
nobody else does yeah and they can't
even the kids don't know those places
sure yeah and that contentment piece is
big and i feel like that's one thing
with money it's not just the dollars and
the sense and the math right there is a
there's such a heart emotional level and
you guys have done such a such an
incredible job with that okay so were
there people that thought you were
absolutely crazy because they're like
you're a pharmacist dude like you guys
are like killing it
um we definitely had some people that
were probably not directly to our face
maybe behind our back i don't know
most of our friends and especially our
family were super helpful during this
whole process you know we could not have
done this without their support so
super thankful for them and their
support absolutely i think the craziest
thing we got was wait you did what with
your credit cards yeah
so yeah
what you don't care about your credit
well you don't need a credit score don't
you want a house someday and so
definitely that was i think that was the
biggest
uh judgment we got for sure yeah of that
and you felt though the pressure though
of people going out and doing stuff yes
so whether it was vacations or car
whatever it is but you guys saying no
and did and do you feel like what you
guys went through together as a couple
which you're you're still newly married
right just two years but do you do you
feel that sense of bonds now with him as
his wife and you as her husband of like
man we can do this we kind of just said
the impossible of what people would say
is impossible for sure yeah there's like
three things we can't do and like
obviously the pandemic adds a whole
nother piece right so but i mean we were
already kind of locked in so that helped
a little bit you know you're stuck in
your house what else are you gonna do um
but um definitely i feel like the bond
has grown stronger and it was it was
definitely a testament to those first
two years
yes you know like but if we can get
through that we can get through anything
amen amen
well done you guys we're proud of you
unbelievable
unbelievable i mean that is that is a
huge huge feat well we have a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you guys
because that is the next leg of your
journey which i'm so excited about
because you guys are so young and i'm
like my future for you it's just it's
incredible absolutely incredible and
we'll give you a copy of total money
makeover as well to pass on to tell all
those people who could have been
whispering behind your back
they can do it too they can do it too
all right we have ryan and michaela from
knoxville tennessee who paid off 193
thousand dollars and 32 months making
107 to 170
a year
all right count it down let's hear a big
debt-free scream all right three two
one
we're dead free
yeah
[Applause]
oh man
is a mountain to climb a hundred and
ninety three thousand dollars in a
student loan first order of business out
of school boom
it's amazing
it's those decisions to me when there's
callers like that that it's it is so all
the journeys are impressive right anyone
that decides to tackle this subject in
their life and get out of debt is always
impressive but when you have younger
people i don't know maybe it's like a
kindred spirit a knoxville sharing of
our life i don't know what it is but i'm
like when i see younger people and
there's a level of maturity there to say
and you say it all the time a definition
of maturity is learning to delay
pleasure and just to say okay we're
getting these checks we're making this
income and we're choosing
to stay in the one bedroom apartment
we're choosing to be uncomfortable we're
choosing to do this for such a short
period of time that sacrifice right is
such a short period of time for such
long-term gains we make a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year in about the
next 20 minutes and they got no payments
in the world do whatever they want
that's a pretty cool place to be i mean
you get to like keep your money and
stuff
have you come and use it the most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and when you get to keep it
you'll become wealthy the stress of
money and marriage is now lowered no
payments and they are on the same team
absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well building wealth seems like a hot
topic right now so whether gosh it's
crypto or single stocks zero down real
estate
the metaverse i mean there's all this
stuff
happening and it feels like everyone has
an opinion and then you add inflation on
top and then everyone's freaking out and
man it's just
it's hard right now with your money to
navigate and know what to do so that is
why we decided to take our building
wealth live event on the road this year
so
vegas we're coming for you orlando
you're you're next week after next for
vegas i know it's coming up may 5th just
a few minutes and then in the fall we're
doing sacramento minneapolis and san
antonio so there's uh there's gonna be a
lot of travel coming up with a really
really fun event so we're gonna again
tackle
these quick uh get rich quick trends and
we're gonna dive into investing in real
estate and uh retirement all of it and
give you the truth and the best way to
build wealth
so vegas may 5th like you said uh the
week after next we'll be in orlando may
19th and then for the fall sacramento
november 1st
minneapolis november 10th and san
antonio november 15th and tickets are
just five dollars or you can get a four
pack for only sixty dollars
and bring your friends it's gonna be a
fun night our events are so fun we we
enjoy ourselves on stage as speakers we
have fun the audience has fun and you
get to learn and hopefully change your
family tree so go to ramseysolutions.com
events to get your tickets before
they're gone again ramsay solutions.com
events to get your tickets and hopefully
we will see you there yeah we'll have
five of our ramsey personalities there
rachel cruz george campbell me uh ken
coleman and dr john deloney will all be
there we'll all be signing books and
we'll all be doing uh roundtable
discussion as well as speaking and
teaching it's gonna be a lot of fun yeah
it is a fun event it's a little bit of a
different one we did one in january and
you do a lot of the keynote at the
beginning so dave does a lot of the
teaching and then at the end we sit
around a table and have these
discussions because again whether it's
inflation student loans uh crypto i mean
there's just so many elements of money
right now resignation yeah i love it so
much is going on so we just sit and have
a conversation and it's it's fun so come
check it out if you're in any of those
cities again uh we have vegas in orlando
this spring ramsay solutions.com
events blinds.com
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means that if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promo codes
around every month you'll save even more
use promo code ramsay to get the best
deal
today's question comes from ethan in
delaware my wife and i are in baby step
three we've agreed that we would have my
mother-in-law come live with us for her
in her older years but rather than put
her rather than put her in a home
however with a nudge from us she has
just barely started contributing 40 a
month to a 401k she's 55 years old and
earns about 15 to 20 an hour we're happy
to help contribute to a mutual fund to
help her now however she does not seem
to feel the same urgency we do
how do we get her to see the importance
of retirement planning
it's like leading a horse to water and
trying to force it to drink isn't that
i mean it it is difficult because in one
sense i don't know i'd love your opinion
on this um dave but you know i feel like
generations ago
the idea of having uh i was actually
reading this in dr john zolone's book um
today actually i was reading it about
the past generation you know the older
generation would move back in with the
younger not because of i don't think the
lack of financial support that they
needed
but just of having a multi-generational
home and that's how society was i mean
hundreds of years ago right and so today
we've obviously evolved in and it is so
different so there is a an element of
this beauty of having her come back with
you guys um and live in the home i mean
i think there's an element of that
that's so wonderful but not because she
can't financially support herself right
so there's
there's that weird balance of the
is it enabling is it honoring right like
that that's such a hard line for me
sometimes yeah
i don't i don't know how you get someone
to see the importance of retirement
planning the only thing you can do is
just start talking to her about
things that you guys are doing
and and it really probably your wife's
gonna have a lot more influence with her
mom than you will unless you have an
unusual relationship with your
mother-in-law
um in my case um you know
you know we've been measuring i've been
married almost 40 years so her dad's as
apt to listen to me now as he would be
to listen to her
so uh but early in your marriage that
would probably be different uh
and so you you don't necessarily
necessarily earn the right by hanging
around long enough to uh
to start telling her what to do but you
know i think the thing you could do is
just say hey listen i read this book and
it changed everything for me uh it'd be
really cool why don't you read it or
i'll get you the audio book and maybe
maybe get her the audio book and the
total money makeover book and give it to
her or something like that just
something to get her spurred along and
get her concerned about and the other
thing is she probably is living hand to
mouth at 15 to 20 an hour because she's
not on a budget she's got a tight budget
with a lower income and so if you can
get her on a budget then she can start
to see that she if she was careful she
could put some money aside then maybe
that hope would kick in because she may
feel overwhelmed uh
and not really know what to do next and
if you can give her kind of give her a
foothold on the first step on the path
then
um
you know maybe she can start to see the
light a little bit yeah i feel like
that's true
with money in general we get the
question a lot of hey how do i
convince my brother-in-law or my you
know i mean or my friend and you get
this a lot and
really whether it's logic by showing
literal dollars on a sheet of paper and
showing a plan that can kind of get them
moving or bringing in that third party
and i feel like we end up being that
third party for a lot of people hey
listen to this podcast or
you know here's a great book or the
third option too is just your own
uh testimony like your own experience of
what you've done and how you have felt
lighter
and giving a get out of debt book away
is like like giving a weight loss book
away it's kind of can be shaming you got
to be real careful and so you're like uh
hey you're stupid you need to read this
that doesn't work okay so in instead you
go hey i read this and i'm giving it to
everybody because it changed my life
you know and it's like because i was so
stupid in this area and you just own
your stuff kind of yeah and then you
just like i'm just you know and so if
somebody gives me a nutrition book that
way
i i you know it stands it sits on the
desk for a day longer than going
straight in the trash totally well if
they just give it to me and go you're
kind of looking fat ramsey you know then
that's probably not going to work for me
and not a great motivator for you
that's good
all right we're going to look to the
phones now and alex from detroit is up
next hey alex welcome to the show
thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help
so i've got a side hustle
part-time business moonlighting for the
past few years and i just recently had
an opportunity come about where someone
may be interested in purchasing it
and just trying to figure out how to
value the business
what do you do very difficult
very difficult because you're a one-man
show right
yes how much of you make on the side
hustle
uh
revenue or net
either one
uh 40 revenue
and net
23 and a half okay so you have a
part-time job that pays you 23 and a
half and you own your job
yeah we're doubling every year yeah okay
no shame in it but that's really what's
going on because if you don't show up
nothing is made
currently yes you're the ceo the chief
everything officer what do you what is
it alex what kind of what kind of side
hustle is it
manufacturing okay
what does that mean
uh we make cosmetics
[Music]
okay so what is it that has value in the
business
what is it that's attracting this buyer
okay um
we've got uh
numerous we've got uh
20 or so clients
that purchased products from us were
mostly wholesale
so
um
having the access to those clients but
also the
uh the formulary know-how
if i owned the business and i had to pay
you to do what you do what would i have
to pay you
um
that's a great question in this current
market
part time
yeah part time maybe 15. okay so then
the difference in that is the actual net
profit after i pay you
and that times five
or times four
is the is what the business is worth so
let's call it ten thousand dollars net
and say that the business is worth
somewhere around 50 000 bucks
unless you have
a recipe in those cosmetics that is more
valuable than the actual cash flow so
far
that's it
well fun hosting with you you too you're
a great co-host dave bryan
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love
create amazing relationships deal with
your career your mental wellness
everything involved rachel cruz
best-selling author my daughter is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five the call is free and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it
so rachel
these people just got married
made good morning america oh yes with a
500
dollar
wedding
and her wedding dress was 47
and i thought
gain i will give you
if you don't have the money right like
that's the point they were like their
goal was they didn't want to go into
debt good morning america did a full
uh feature on them the other day and uh
abc news our friends up there
um
uh this couple uh kyra and joel
broken
bro brawl i can't say
bro bro broken bro i guess it is john
um we're able to pull everything off for
just 500
uh in los angeles which is way less than
the nearly thirty thousand dollar
national average
uh for a wedding
and
their goal was just to be as minimal as
possible kyra said uh and to spend the
least amount of money possible the bride
and groom said they were able to do that
by putting a heavy focus on not going
into debt while starting their marriage
way to go guys
kind of people
that's our people right there i like you
yeah so
uh she apparently bought the dress
online for 47 and i thought it was going
to be when i was reading this and looked
at the article i thought it was going to
be one of those um
uh deals
i don't know consignment there's a thing
where the like the prom dresses and
stuff and all that yeah yeah that you
can
that's a but that's a rental thing isn't
it yeah i mean there's there's all kinds
of things but hers was a legit beautiful
white
dress that yeah she just found a deal on
it yeah yeah yeah
and it's probably honestly was not
called a wedding dress like it was a
long i saw the picture was beautiful
just a long white very elegant looking
dress but it's like a cocktail dress
when they put like um well cocktails
shorts oh i'm sorry it was it was a
full-length gown it wasn't i will i will
educate you on that but uh no but i
watched the clip too and
and she
a lot of their family helped with
certain things so like that her aunt did
the flowers
uh her sister had a beautiful
like runner for the aisle and they got
married i thought this was great the
venue was free because it was literally
on the side of the road in l.a yeah so
like one of those pull-offs that you
pull off
on the side and it's a huge overlook in
the ocean yeah it was beautiful and it
was a in the i guess they just pacific
highway and everyone just parked right
there and they got white chairs right
down so she probably ran into the chairs
probably part of the 500 budget
uh the fine from the highway patrol was
2 000 but the wedding was 500
i don't know but they did it i was like
this is brilliant like it was great and
it was beautiful too because she said
she was like listen it's our wedding and
we didn't want to go into debt for it
and this is what we had one day it's one
day and it's and it's to show and bear
witness to the fact that we are giving
vows to each other to
be before god before god and a lifelong
commitment and the people there and so
the guests paid for their own food and
drink at the reception and she said they
didn't mind because they knew what they
were doing she was like they were saying
you did that because not because you
were cheap but because you're trying to
stay out of debt or get out of debt or
something 100 you told me uh i i would i
would definitely pick up my food and
drink at the reception as a guest and i
will pick up somebody else's yep you
know i just think it's so cool and uh
you know i mean there might have been
some little
uh
i don't know some little niche or
something that didn't think it was cool
but i bet all the old people loved it oh
absolutely and again it's because there
it there's a greater why for it all
right they they didn't go into that so
anyways it was awesome so great gosh so
great versus there was a story actually
was on good morning america about two
years ago to do a segment on weddings
and it was like they covered this one
wedding and it was like photo booths and
fondue fat all of the stuff which is not
bad and i i want to say that you can
have a great big wedding if you can pay
for it but they were taking out a
personal loan
for the expenses of their wedding right
so we did a whole segment on it but i'm
like that
versus this
so polar opposite and
there's just there's there's such a
beauty in that contentment piece that i
think is just awesome so
very cool we've had big weddings in the
ramsey family you and your sister your
brother we just love big parties and we
love big celebrations and and so we've
enjoyed
that but we could afford to write
whatever check that was it wasn't
completely unreasonable you gave us a
budget but um we did give you a budget
um it was a nice budget but it was a
budget
and um so but but just the same i mean
this is
uh
i i'm thinking of other people on our
team here who have gotten married lots
of them for under ten thousand dollars
lots of under ten thousand dollar
weddings um and and here's the thing
it's one day
i mean if you said i'm gonna go out to
eat and spend thirty thousand dollars
you would shoot i mean you would go no
no because it's one day i'm gonna go on
a one-day vacation
you know i'm going to this place and
we're going to stay one night and one
day and the cost is ten thousand dollars
or thirty thousand dollars you would be
going what but that's essentially what a
wedding i mean it's a one day thing or
two day thing with a rehearsal dinner
but you know oh my gosh
yeah so uh it's okay to do it you just
need to have the money but uh we've
created this um
expectation almost of what it should be
yeah it's just crazy it's almost created
by the by the businesses around it too
the diamond industry the uh the i don't
know who
but we've romanticized in america
weddings uh in india and america the
weddings are both just over the top
but most other cultures they're not and
so i just love this i think it's so
mature
and uh they're really married before god
she said and uh and before their friends
and they're they they're gonna have a
great life it's awesome um and i just
way to go hats off from the ramseys so
guys pretty incredible the ramsey team
here brought this to us and said we
wanted to salute you guys you know what
i told daniel my brother when he got
married i was like listen take the
wedding budget
cut it in half
use the half for the wedding and use the
other half for marriage counseling all
years down the road because working on
your marriage
is a whole lot
has a lot more value
than the day it really does so yeah
that's uh he didn't do it but yeah
neither did you but no i didn't
so i had that advice after
i was like
it's easy it's easy to tell other people
after you're done right
i love it all right we're going to talk
to you about your life and your money so
by the way the average household income
in america is around 60 000 average
budget for a wedding is around 30 000.
so people often ask us about a wedding
that means the average is people spend
half of a year's income that's the
average now do you this is a case where
you'd want to be below average
uh
but if you make a hundred thousand
dollars a year if you spend more than 50
you're out of control and for a wedding
engagement rings
uh my rule of thumb is like one month
one month's income max jewelry store
tell you three but they're in the
jewelry sales business so keep that in
mind
one month max
[Music]
and there is no correlation between the
size of the diamond and the uh
how long the marriage lasts
as a matter of fact there may be an
inverse correlation this is the ramsey
shadow
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host best-selling author today open
phones at
825-5225 hey if you're a small business
owner i get it you got a ton on your
plate lots of big decisions a million
details to take care of so make sure you
protect what you've built commercial
insurance will protect your business
from the financial fallout from
accidents lawsuits vandals and natural
disasters and you don't have to spend a
bunch of time finding a good commercial
insurance
finding good commercial insurance that
you can actually afford because you can
work with one of the ramsey trusted
independent agents these are the same
folks that'll help you shop your car
insurance your homeowners insurance get
the best deal they're endorsed local
providers they're independent agents who
shop a bazillion companies to get you
the best deal so protect your business
protect your car protect your homeowners
get the best deal by shopping around and
they'll do it for you
go to ramsey ramseysolutions.com
commercial and you can connect with one
of our ramsey trusted
agents hey guys we're going to be doing
a
show here in a week or two on college
paying for college scholarships going to
college debt free if you're a parent or
a teen and you have a question about
that or even a comment or a story about
that
we'd like to put you on the air during
that show it's a theme hour and you need
to get in touch with kelly so we can
arrange for you to be on the show with
your question or your comment or your
story ramsay solutions dot com slash ask
ramsey solutions dot com slash ask put
college in the subject line and let
kelly know what it is you'd like to talk
about and we would love to have you
thanks open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five gray is with
us in tampa florida hi gray welcome to
the show
hi thank you for having me hi rachel hi
dave sure how can we help
um
so i finally well my wife and i finally
got scared enough
and mad enough at our debt to stop our
plan and start your plan
and i have heard you mention
in the past there's a couple of things
that you recommend
before baby step one i believe it's term
life insurance and identity theft um
may be a will and the biggest part of
this is
if we are behind on our bills so there's
a couple like a car payment and one
credit card we're behind on is that do
we get current before saving the
thousand or do we save the thousand like
crazy and then get current
um okay the will the term insurance and
um the identity theft insurance are just
simply not a baby step so it's not that
you have to do those before you start
the baby steps but they're all something
you need to do as soon as you can
okay but it might be that you're deep
into baby step two before you actually
implement those
uh i wouldn't say you have to get those
done before you start baby step one as
far as getting caught up on your bills
yeah i would get caught up on your bills
um and that's your that's your first
thing let's get to even let's get to
even and
uh the good news is you've already
started concentrating on this and so
when you do this month's budget you'll
probably get even won't you
yes it'll probably be about three weeks
to get even yeah okay all right so what
happened gray i'm curious for you guys
you said we got mad enough and scared
enough um
what was well i got the
biggest paycheck um single week paycheck
in the history of my life
and it wasn't enough to pay all of our
bills
and
i i was scared my wife was scared the
day before we got the paycheck because
she saw how much it was going to be and
said that's not enough
and
then i heard a debt frame free screen
from some people last week that they had
a construction company they sold like
kitchen counters or something and in
three years they paid off over a million
and i was like that's it i see the light
at the end of the tunnel we can do this
and um eventually we won't have to be
scared but right now we're scared but
there's a solution that's not ours that
we can get there yeah how old are you
guys
i am 31 and my wife is 32. how long you
been married
four years
okay how much are your car payments
um
one vehicle is three hundred and
forty dollars and the other vehicle is
360. okay
probably need to sell one of them
okay
you got 700 car payments what's your
household income
uh take home about 63 000 a year i know
you need to sell one of them
okay and you get to pick which one but
it's probably yours not hers so
that's definitely my pickup truck okay
so here's the thing um you said like
five times that you're scared and it's a
good scared because it's the kind of
scared that says i gotta get out of the
middle of the road a truck's coming
right that's a good scared
um
but with that um
i've been where you are and i remember
how it feels to have your stomach in
your throat
and not be able to breathe
and i know how terrified my wife was and
we were your age
okay
so number one
piece of information that you need to
tell your wife tonight
number one cause of divorce in north
america today of money pro of marital
fights marital discord
is money stress number one cause
and you're square in the middle of it
and that terror
that she feels and that
hit on your self-esteem that you feel
because you can't seem to get it
together up until today
okay
it is uh
they feed on each other she's afraid her
claws come out that makes you feel less
when you feel less that makes her more
afraid and it's a really vicious circle
okay
so you guys have to look at each other
take her hands in your hands give her a
big hug and go okay
we're doing this together um we are not
going to live like this anymore and we
are not going to let this take our
marriage and as a matter of fact it's
going to make our marriage stronger
but you have to say it out loud okay
i i can do that and we can do that yeah
because i i don't want that to sneak up
on you because even if you had even if
you thought you had a really good
marriage and you me you may you may but
this is the ultimate stressor
on a marriage so just know that you know
if the number one p way people die in
your area is bear attack
there is a bear in your living room okay
and so you go oh this is a problem it's
the number one thing right so uh yeah
really don't let the bear in the living
room and so um that's what you got to do
you got to put your arms around her and
hold on tight for the ride now we're
going to put you into ramsey plus which
will plug you into financial peace
university i want you to go through the
classes together we'll put you in every
dollar the premium app it's part of it
too or you can do the budget together
and there's going to be a lot of people
in there that are facing the same kind
of stuff you're facing we'll put you
into a group it's all on us we're gonna
pay for it because i've been where
you've been the only thing i request is
that you do everything we tell you to do
and you go when
and then the second thing is someday
when you're rich you give it to some
young couple that's scared okay
absolutely thank you so much for your
generosity
and if you get scared and you don't know
what to do on some little detail thing
as you're working this you call us again
we're here for you okay
okay thank you all right god bless you
brother
that's uh
that's most people
yeah
yep
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck when you drive down the street
eight out of 10 houses on your street
have too much month left at the end of
the money normal in the this country
today is broke and that sucks
it's not okay
it's not okay
and that's the bad news the good news is
you can do something about it
you get to wake up every day make a
decision and i love even the the selling
the car so mathematically absolutely but
there's almost this like jilt in your
system that you need when you've been
doing the same thing even though it's
wrong over and over and over and over
you become comfortable you become
familiar with it
and it's almost like when you change
course and you do something like this
and you just do something that feels
radical and he's like oh it's going to
be my truck selling the truck like it's
going to hurt it's not going to be fun
but you're going to get my credit cards
i'm going to sell the truck i'm not
going out to eat i'm gonna do some
radical stuff i'm not living like this
anymore
you gotta have that thing happen down
inside of you
when you do
you'll be ready baby and we're here to
help we can show you how
but uh you can you can wander into debt
but you can't wander out it's not an
intellectual exercise you got to get so
pissed off you can't breathe i'm getting
out
and that's right where he is he's scared
and he's mad and oh that's a really good
place to be this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage candace
is with us hey candace how are you i'm
fine
good to have you good to have you where
do you live indianapolis indiana awesome
and all the way here to do a debt-free
screen yep how much do you pay off
234 000 oh my gosh
how long did this take 31 months look at
you
i love it and your range of income
during that time
74 000 to 270
000.
oh what do you do for a living i'm a
nurse practitioner so you went to travel
nursing huh i did not i stayed um as a
nurse practitioner full-time and then i
worked in the hospital as a nurse
full-time as well and then i had another
part-time mp job
so you're doing 80 90 hours a week 96.
you're a beast girl
i want to know i want to know your
schedule what did what did a typical day
cause you worked every day during the
week yep so i did
not nine hours on monday tuesday after
monday and tuesday
i worked at my third job on mondays
tuesday i did four hours in my second
job wednesdays i do nine hours i take a
two hour nap then i go to the hospital
for 12 hours
then i take a nap and then i do six
hours
on thursdays
fridays
9 or 10 hours nap 12 hours 12 to 16
hours on saturday how long did you do
this
um 96 hours i did that for the last
probably
nine months and then 80 hours before
that before that
what are you down to now that you're
free um i'm still working a lot but i'm
throwing in vacations with it
you kind of got the rhythm now
okay what kind of debt was the 234
thousand dollars this must be all the uh
all the schools had huh it was a hundred
and fourteen thousand school loans
thirty thousand in one car and sixteen
thousand in another car
um 10 000 in taxes
30 000 in credit cards
and
65 000 on a mortgage you paid off your
house
okay no i mean you're single why you
have two cars
because i drove a con convertible
no no in indianapolis it snows and it's
icy yeah
yeah oh my god
you kept them you kept them and painted
them i have both yeah
okay so what happened
what happened months ago that just made
you say 31 months 31 months ago
you went crazy i mean man i guess about
four or five years ago i bought um dave
ramsey's um
the debt-free makeover and i put it to
the side because i was in school and i
couldn't focus and then when i graduated
with my master's degree about a month
after i spent all my credit card money
used on my credit cards and you
realizing that all my money was going to
credit card debt car loans i picked up
the book and i read it in two days and
it was just life transforming for me
from there
so i started budgeting
i was davish initially and then the end
of 2020 um i kind of put the gas on i
went gazelle intense kind of was um
disappointed in myself because i did a
lot of traveling trying to pay
everything off and i realized where i
could have been um so
2021 january until september when i paid
my school loans off i pretty much did 80
hours and then the last three months i
paid my school loans off i did 96 and
then i kind of kept going and then
finished my mortgage off in march wow
look at you
yeah
you are amazing you're a machine this is
so good was it worth all that
absolutely
absolutely how you feel i feel free so
that's probably the best term that i can
use i feel free
a bit overwhelmed before weren't you
absolutely overwhelmed discouraged
so
scared scared yeah so tell me this
canvas because there's probably people
listening that could be in a very
similar situation of what you were 32
months ago right and they're thinking
but there's no way i can do this there's
no way
i mean this is going to be my life what
would you say to people
that think that way that it's just
impossible they've lost all hope what
would you say
um
i would say just keep pushing
set a goal stick to it um realize that
the plan can change a million times like
mines did but the goal never changed
yeah my goal was to become debt free and
i'm there free
just eye on the prize yes i love it wow
so um
where did you learn to work like that
my mother okay
yeah so she was the workers your mom's a
wild animal huh yeah she's a single mom
of four she works oh yeah two jobs
always doing overtime so i've always
had good work work ethic yeah um so if i
want to do if i want something i go work
for it basically that's it that's it no
other way don't sell that convertible
you just i won't work
i'm gonna just go work extra hours wait
i love it yeah oh okay so what were
people saying during this journey
because people had to be looking i mean
we do this for a living and we're still
just like wait what you working 96 hours
a week uh yeah what was everyone saying
a lot of people were inspired a lot of
people that i work with because of
course i spent a lot of time with them
and my friends of course um i didn't
really share my journey with
everybody until i got down to my last
three months of having my school loans
off and my friends were talking about it
to people so they were inspired and like
you should share it so i started posting
and then i did the rings
paying the last fifty thousand of my
school loans so a lot of people were in
tune with that so it was really really
inspiring for me and for them so it was
really really nice they were definitely
inspired a lot of people were
discouraged because they're like oh i
don't make that much well you don't have
234 000 in debt either
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is just being
consistent
always knowing that you have to
sacrifice
um learning the
aspect of delayed gratification you know
everything we want we usually want it
now
and knowing that sometimes it just takes
time you know even with you know wanting
a new car
you know save up the money
wait and then you know you can get your
car or whatever it is that you want just
to delay gratification and getting away
from instant gratification was probably
the biggest key for me
how old are you 31. your mama's gotta be
looking at you with tears running down
her face i'm really really proud yes
yeah i'm proud of you thank you well
done it's pretty incredible you're an
incredible young woman
and folks you don't have to work like
this your whole life she just did it for
a short period of time yeah to hit a
goal and uh but she knows she can
and you really can't work like that for
five years in a row you can't
your body can't stand it your emotions
can't stand it but for a short period of
time you can turn it on
and really for just under a year you've
been going like a maniac
and uh and now you're free completely
free i figured you went
uh the way the numbers jumped i figured
you went travel nursing that's why i
jumped on that but instead you just took
a zillion hours picked up another
full-time job yeah and there's two
full-time jobs and then a part-time job
yeah and it's all around nursing yeah
and uh always a need isn't there for
nursing
always a shortage yeah great career path
so proud of you wow you're amazing
absolutely amazing absolutely we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that is the next chapter in your story
for sure without a doubt how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth and
how you can too the daughter of a single
mom raising four kids learned how to
work
by watching her mama yep our mama as you
say rachel morris caught and taught yep
she saw it and uh yeah and i knew she
could and had the confidence i mean
there's a confidence that you have that
you're like i can do this i can do this
that's right not a victim she's a victor
it's amazing pretty incredible pretty
incredible beautiful stuff it's changed
your life copy a total money makeover
for you to give away to somebody and uh
maybe you can get them started and stir
up a ruckus like you did i have you are
you are something else you are something
else you are amazing all right candace
from indianapolis 234 thousand dollars
paid off in 31 months she did it in two
and a half years 96 hours a week for the
last nine months house and everything
and she's 31 years old two cars single a
hundred percent debt free wow count it
down let's hear a debt free screen
one two three
i'm deaf free
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones
[Music]
two
at
five two two five thank you for joining
us america we're so glad you're here it
is a free call we're talking about
building wealth doing work that you love
having amazing relationships and
completely changing your family tree
brook is with us in phoenix arizona hi
brooke welcome to the ramsey show
hi hi gabe hi rachel thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's up
okay so help me out here so we
want to either sell our current home
which has gone
um up to 470 thousand dollars in value
we only owe 78 000 on it
and use that equity to put in a new
property
um that is worth 7.25
um
or if we should stay in our current
house and pay it off now it's 1300
square feet we're a growing family we're
doing ivf again in june
um we want to know whether we should
upgrade now the property that 725
is unique because it's a family member's
property it's three and a half acres it
has a manufactured home on it so it's
not huge and it's not a real house and
it also has a barn that he converted
into a detached apartment it's really
nice anyway
we want to buy this property um and he
said he would carry us for five years at
zero percent interest
um
and we're wanting to hopefully build a
new home in five to seven years on it so
it's going to be a huge investment our
financial advisor
keeps telling us
no don't do it your money is making
money in the bank
wait until your house is paid off and
then use our current residence
as a rental for the future and for our
retirement plan we're currently debt
free other than the 78 000
mortgage we paid off 200 000 um in five
years on my pa school loans
and we paid off both of our cars last
year
um we are self-employed so it was
difficult to get a loan we did hear back
that we could get a loan that seven
percent
so um that was really high
if we put down our if we sell our house
we estimate about a 365 000
profit plus we've already saved up um
225 000 earmarked for
our future house
so this uncle would only be carrying us
for five years at around twenty two
hundred dollars a month so we'd be
debt-free again in five years but for
sure we'd want household income
so that it's between 94 to 125 and i'm a
pa however dave i do want to say that i
haven't really worked the past three
years because
the reason we have
we got a settlement from major hospital
because um
they made a medical error that killed my
little boy
and um
yeah and
the ink is still wet because we just
signed it um
and i didn't want to bring it up because
i don't want to cry um but okay
immediately right when we got that money
so we were left with um
after 40 we had to give the attorneys we
were left with around
um
like 800 900 000 but we immediately paid
off um
our cars and i had already paid off two
hundred thousand dollars on my school
loans and we only owed twenty seven
thousand i immediately paid that
um i left my mortgage on until i could
talk to you because we only have
interest
of the settlement money you have 200
left
no i'm sorry no no the rest is um we
have around so we have 669 in cash and
the rest is in mutual funds so okay so
669 in cash we have another 200 mutual
funds
yeah 291 in mutual funds plus um
we
we started our retirement not you said
your family you said your family's
growing and how big is your family now
well um i had twins and so that's hard
question for me to answer because my
little boy died so i do have two one
angel in heaven and one here and we're
doing ivf again in next month okay all
right so you have one child on the on
earth and one in heaven and um hopefully
another on the way
yes okay and you're in 1300 square feet
yeah
okay and we've lived there for 13 years
we haven't even though i was making
living in a barn doesn't sound fun to me
no no no no that would be a rental um no
but you if you sell your house if you
sell your house you're going to be
living in a trailer or living in a barn
i'll tell you
yes
okay
so your uncle doesn't need your uncle
doesn't need to carry you you have the
money to pay for the property
we do but my financial advisors i don't
care what your financial advisor said
you called me
yeah no that's why i'm calling you
[Laughter]
i'm paying cash for the property
and then i'm going to build a house
start building a house immediately
really okay
yeah if you're going to live on that
property that would go into our
retirement no
i thought you said you had 669 in the
bank and 200 in in mutual funds
you didn't that wasn't retirement
that wasn't retirement well the
mutual fund i thought is um a part of
retirement i'm sorry is that some of
that 200 in retirement accounts like
401k or roth ira broke or is it just on
it just
standard mutual funds do you know no 291
no the 291 includes the roth there's 24
000 in
our roth how much do you have that is
not in retirement in addition to the 669
cash
okay subtract this for me because i
can't look at my calculator right now so
291 minus 24 minus 30 000 which is in my
daughter's atma and we have 85 000 in
our savings account for emergency okay a
little heavy on your emergency fund
okay my financial advisor told me
well three to six months is enough of
expenses and your three to six months of
expenses is not 85 000
so if you sell the property that you're
in and you move in the trailer or the
barn temporarily while you build
and you have um it sounds to me like you
can buy the property for 700 000 and
that what you said
yeah you have 700 000 in non-retirement
money now
and you'll get the other money out of
the sale of your house
well no 669 in cash i know we'd have to
sell it i know and then you gave me all
these other numbers was that in the 669
or in addition to the 669
no the 669 is just cash okay and then
you've got 85
and then you've got other money
and then you've got other money that's
not the 529 and not the 401 k
yeah when you add those numbers together
you're well a north of seven hundred
thousand and you have the equity in your
house it's around 400k
so you're saying we'll have enough i'm
saying pay cash for the property and
then build you a house on the property
for three or four hundred thousand
dollars you may end up with a small
mortgage in that process
okay only on the bills
the interest rates would be i don't want
to be owing my uncle anything
right well we'd pay them off and i don't
care don't borrow money from relatives
okay the borrower's slave calendar
yeah you are yeah you are
oh you don't pay you don't pay him he's
gonna foreclose
yeah that's borrowed money kiddo
yeah you're stepping up into a noose
you're stepping up into a problem and
you're getting ready change your
relationship with your uncle
i'm not sure this house is the best
house i'm not sure this property is the
best property i think you're only
looking at it because he brought it to
you and set it on your doorstep and the
zero interest sounded good i think you
might i'll just go get you a nice house
move up in house and sell your house and
pay cash for it yeah i think that's
actually what i'd do i don't think i'd
screw with this deal i think i'd let him
keep it
just to look around and dream because
brokeman if you guys had that 400
i'm like that's north of i mean like you
got you got a lot of money that you're
able to say you got a million dollars
you can throw at something just go dream
just look around and say what could we
do for a million dollars i bet you could
go find a really nice house for 700 000
and pay cash for it and end up with
three or four hundred thousand laying
around
after you move in
and move you know double the house the
quality of the house you're in get you a
nice bigger property that'll you don't
have to build you you've been through
all this problem you've been through the
loss of a child you've been through uh
the infertility treatments you've been
through all this stuff you've been
through the court you've been through
all this other stuff i i don't think i
want the stress of building a house if
i'm you
i built a couple of them it's not that
big a deal you can do it but i if i were
you i just go get me a house
and i'd let the uncle keep his property
actually i'm really gonna push you to do
that and i really think your financial
advisor has way too much to say about
your money you're supposed to tell him
what to do not him tell you what to do
it's your money
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author my daughter is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call triple eight eight two
five five two five we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create absolutely amazing
relationships change your family tree
it's what it's all about it's life right
here on the radio mike is with us mike
is in lexington hey mike how are you
hi dave and rachel thank you for taking
my call sure what's up um
i've got a 529 that i started for my
daughter years ago
and now my daughter is older and has
pretty much disowned me
um
what should i do
what should i do with that 529 since
i don't see any
uh future reconnection with my with my
daughter
i'm sorry
that's awful um
how old how old is she
she's 16. it's it's due to
parent manipulation
yeah oh i'm sorry mike
um
well you you how much is in there
uh 16 grand okay
uh i can give you the legal technical
answer
the legal technical answer is the money
is hers it's in her name
and you put yourself in the seat of the
manager of her money
and you have a legal responsibility to
manage her money for her
and it the
the setup doesn't account for
relationship one way or the other
okay okay and so it's her money
uh you don't have a choice in that
technically
um
now uh on a practical level
if you cash it out um you're probably
gonna have some taxes on it a little bit
um
and
it doesn't sound to me like anybody's
gonna bother you
but you hypothetically could get sued
later
if uh that you stole her money or
something you know that kind of thing
uh so
i'm not suggesting you do that i'm just
telling you that it's 16 000 bucks it's
not it's not 1.6 million
so um but uh vindictive
kids from manipulative parents uh in a
split up situation you never know so i
don't know what you do with it it's up
to you
um what i i i assume you've got this
with a a financial advisor right
no not yet
okay who's the who's the 529 with
it's it's through our state
it's not through a financial advisor
okay you might contact them and ask them
if you can transfer
the custodianship
to her mom
in other words take your name off of the
responsibility line
and transfer the line of responsibility
to her mom and then her mom is in charge
of the money
uh for her until she's 21 like you're in
charge of the money for her until she's
21 right now
and that would get you out of the
loop
um that's probably the cleanest thing
you can do do you have other kids mike
no it's just a single daughter okay but
you don't have children with another
marriage or anything else
no sir okay
all right
um
yeah i mean i'm just trying i'm trying i
i i can't get past the
the knot i have in my throat from just
the whole idea of this but
um but but aside from that the practical
thing is
if you get it out of your
otherwise you are are bound to resp you
know to manage this for her for her
education
and um i guess she has to come to you
for that then if you want to leave it
there as bait
um you
can right well even if even if i were to
remove that money
um
through my disability with the military
she's still
you know i'd still cover her for
a portion of the tuition for any you
still can't
you still can
but you're not required to
the military benefit doesn't require it
and she can't access it without going
through you the military benefit or the
529.
so how long have you all been split up
you and the x
oh me and the x have been split for
11 years now okay and how how long has
your daughter
made the decision that she doesn't want
to contact with you
about a year
okay
um
can i change hats
i'm just going to be dad
um
i wouldn't do anything
i would just let her mother know and i
would write her some letters they may or
may not get through to her just telling
her how much you love her
and that you're here and then when she
gets ready to call to college there's a
college fund and that there's a military
benefit and all she's got to do is get
in contact with you and you'll be happy
to help her with that
and i would just let that lay there
yeah because she's 16 mike and i'm like
man she she's gonna come around i i
i have hope that there you know what i
mean it's um
that there's still years and obviously
she's still gonna be living i'm assuming
with your ex to you may not feel like
it's going to get better but i wonder as
she gets older
um
even 18 19 20 years old you know what i
mean what what matures in her and her
curiosity towards you all of it you know
she still feels still young even though
it's it's extremely beautiful what was
your relationship with her before all
this
uh we had a fairly decent relationship
she'll come running around just over the
years did something did something happen
mike was there an event that happened or
just over time she was like i just want
anything to do with you
i believe it was overtime okay
there wasn't a set blow up where you did
something
no sir okay i'm gonna let this and the
military benefit lay there because she's
going to come back around and you're
going to be able to bless her and it's
going to be part of the reconciliation
story
okay
that's papa dave talking that's not a
legal financial answer
but it's also correct by the way it's
also legal and it's also financial but
um
um and you know she's got to come
through you to get to that and if she
wants to go to school completely
debt-free uh you've got a military
benefit and she has a college fund that
you funded for and you love her and and
anytime you want to talk i'm here to
talk and
anything you want to you know yell at me
about you can yell at me about and um
you get ready to go to school i'm go i'm
in a position to help you just get in
touch with me at that time and
more than that i want a relationship
with you you know absolutely above and
beyond just about right now that's the
whole point but yeah i think you just
sit with these things and
but and hold them in your hands and
they're an opportunity to bless her as
the reconciliation goes along and um uh
and it's it you know there's just a
natural gravitational pull between a
daughter and her dad unless there's
something really toxic and really wrong
and um okay i um
i've watched it with friends over the
years uh where there's a temporary
shutdown that felt like it was permanent
and they come back around and
they really do feather way of figuring
out the truth
um
sometimes it just takes a little while
i'm sorry
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825.
five
two two five it's a free call
we've talked gods and grandma's ways of
handling money for nearly 30 years here
at ramsey now our good friend and ramsey
personality expert dr john deloney is
paving the way for how we talk about
relationships how we talk about mental
health his brand new book own your past
change your future came out yesterday
it's now available for purchase and it's
a book everyone needs to read this book
is not just for people healing from
traumatic experiences john has practical
steps that apply to everyone in every
walk of life reading this book is like
having john sitting one-on-one with you
offering decades of experience practical
advice and encouragement on topics like
relationships and how to live a more
restful
and peaceful
life get your own copy right now of own
your past
change your future for only 20 bucks
at ramseysolutions.com
john will be on the road this coming
thursday would be tomorrow night he'll
be signing books in phoenix at the
barnes noble on desert ridge marketplace
on tatum boulevard six o'clock thursday
the 21st make sure you make plans to do
that one week from tonight if you're in
dallas on wednesday night april 27th at
6 pm he will be at barnes noble at the
prestonwood town center on beltline road
signing books and so we invite you folks
in dallas to come out and see dr john as
well he'll be talking answering
questions signing books at both of these
locations and you do not want to miss it
you don't want to miss this book it is a
it is it's a life-changing incredible
incredible book
cheyenne is with us in arizona hi
cheyenne welcome to the ramsay show
hi rachel and dave thank you for having
me sure what's up i have a question i'm
55 a widow i'm out of debt and i have
about four hundred thousand dollars just
sitting in the bank
i am one of those um investment
resistant people
i feel like it's out of my control
i have
did a deep dive into trying to invest
and talk to two different people who
were financial people and got very deep
in what they were recommending to me
but as i was
researching it there'd be something
there that i just didn't want to invest
in a mcdonald's or a pepsi or some kind
of chemical farming or things like that
and i
so
you know i've downsized my lifestyle i
i've been a medical person for 30 years
so i'm semi retired i could go back
tomorrow and do that income's not a
problem
i just would like to know
what your opinion is someone like me if
it's let you think oh my goodness it's
not growing
i have a friend that just lost 80 000 in
the last month a whole year of her
income based on the market where she had
the money and that just feels so out of
control for me to put it somewhere where
i have no control
your friend was investing in some kind
of high risk something to lose eighty
thousand dollars in one month
or or she has two million dollars
invested one of the two which is it
okay
well i don't know the person
something to do with their work
okay see that was a high risk single
stock investment and so
that's not see the market represents the
stock market represents everything from
ultra high risk scary crazy stuff down
to things that are just plain boring and
so um when someone says they lost money
in the market it can mean that they were
virtually gambling in las vegas or it
can mean
that they you know that they just panic
every time that the needle moves a
little bit um so but you don't you don't
have a stomach for it is what you're
saying
and you can't i don't have the stomach
for it and you've attempted to uh gain
enough knowledge to get some peace and
it hasn't worked so
um but you can't leave uh four hundred
thousand dollars sitting at one percent
either you that's why you called agreed
uh yes yeah i mean because you're making
nothing
so what about buying some real estate
that creates some income
well i did that two i did two houses and
turned them in during covid but of
course it was coved and so everything
was twice as much and the help was
so i mean i didn't lose but i didn't it
certainly wouldn't show
it wouldn't have been worth it in other
words so that's because if you continue
to jump in and out of things you're
always going to lose money yeah you got
to ride the wave out not necessarily
redoing a property but just buying one
renting it out and having that passive
income if you had a forty thousand
dollar property that i mean four hundred
thousand dollar property that you a
simple piece of you know nice house that
someone rented for three or four
thousand dollars a month
uh you'd be making a whole lot more than
you would on the bank
true uh it's something i don't enjoy
i've had many years of it and and not
the best claim not the best years of it
so cheyenne i have a question
you you presented two problems with
investing one it was companies that you
just didn't agree with morally you
mentioned like pepsi or mcdonald right
i'm guessing you just don't agree with
them as companies and the fear that
you're gonna lose money which is greater
do you feel like which which part of it
makes it like
oh
you know i guess in one sense i'm i i
want to put my money where my heart is
you know and have it
manifest something good on the on the
earth
okay what would that be
no i don't know i've been trying to
search and find it
maybe there's some good funds
where people are christ-centered you
know
you don't find out at the top that
they're
moving against
mankind i'd like to see i'd like to
invest in something that means maybe
food i don't know
well there's um
number one when you're dealing with a
mutual fund
you're dealing with uh
90 to 200 different companies inside of
a mutual fund
and um
at any given time one of those companies
could have some kind of a business
practice
disclosed or undisclosed that somebody
doesn't agree with okay now you're not
giving them money when you buy their
stock okay if you buy
stock in a company from me you gave me
the money
now you are benefiting when they make a
profit and the stock goes up in value uh
you are benefiting from their actions
that you don't agree with and so that
part i do understand but if there's 90
to 200 and one half of one of the
companies is doing something wrong
that's kind of like you shopping at a
grocery store that also sells stuff you
don't agree with but you bought the
stuff you do agree with there
you really can't find any you really
can't find something that's a hundred
percent pure
in this world this side of heaven um if
now i will tell you one thing to
investigate there is a a group out of
atlanta called the timothy fund
the timothy fund
and it is a mutual fund and um
their goal is to invest in companies
that to avoid investing in companies
that engage in
something anything they consider to be
non-christian and so for instance they
don't invest in any tobacco companies or
uh alcohol companies um
they might invest in a chemical company
you don't agree with based on what
you're saying i don't know but um but
yeah the timothy fund is actually done
it's a it's a moral based fund a
christian based idea
um and they've done very well they've
got a good long-term track record uh you
might investigate them and learn about
them i don't have i'm not associated
with them in any way
i don't have any money in there and i'm
not because i'm against them uh it's
just not the prop process i have used to
do analysis for my
my fund picks but um i've been aware of
them for over a decade and they've got
the main central fund has probably got a
now it's probably got a 20-year track
record and it's it's beating the market
and uh
so and i would say to shine if you if
you decide to step into something
because you're wanting to make more than
just one percent you don't have to just
do all five hundred thousand like
do fifty thousand for a year and see how
that feels and maybe you take another
hundred thousand right like you can kind
of
move your way into this um but for your
benefit long term
uh for you to even be generous on the
other end to be able to give some money
away to things that you really do care
about um
making that money and i've heard of that
i appreciate your pure heart but that
bank is paying you one percent i'll
guarantee you they're engaged in things
you don't like
i can just a hundred percent guarantee
that
so there's not a place you can hide
from that no i'll just promise you
they're
they're donating the things you don't
agree with i can promise you they are
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
andrew and stephanie are with us andrew
mcguire is our associate director of
analytics he's been with ramsey for
about four years he's been a team member
here for quite a while and a really
bright young man but a team member
debt-free screen one of our favorite
things to do
hey andrew and stephanie how you all
doing doing well dave how are you very
cool very cool all right how much debt
did you pay off we paid off two hundred
and thirty eight thousand dollars no how
long did that take it took three years
nine months and 20 days three years nine
months and 20 days i'm not gonna ask the
income because all your co-workers are
standing around that'd be weird
so uh wow what kind of debt was the 238
thousand this was the house yeah
[Applause]
oh baby step seven
i love it you're so weird absolutely
amazing and a baby on the way baby on
the way when's baby dude in august all
right
very cool number three number three
number three awesome
i love it
all right so three years nine months and
20 days uh so that's uh you've been
working on the house after you got here
that's right yeah when we moved down
here we bought our uh first house and
set a plan to have it paid off within
five years and you did it in three years
3.9 yeah i love it
very cool how old are you two oh we're
31 years old okay man and what's the
house worth uh somewhere around 650 000.
man i've got a whole bunch of
millionaires working
i had another guy come up to me the
other day a young guy and he said i just
passed the million-dollar mark there you
go i mean uh we got millionaires working
here you got to come to work for ramsey
we got millionaires here i'm just saying
you guys way to go man thank you i'm not
going to ask about the other and prove
that you're a millionaire but you're
right they're real close anyway with
your 401k and other stuff so good job
man wow very very neat
ah man all right so tell us the story
you come to work for ramsey and that
finishes it up what you're already
working on or tell how's all this weave
together yeah so our story really began
about six and a half years ago
i was taking fpu at a local church just
trying to get my finances in order
didn't have any debt at the time but
wasn't really budgeting consistently
and while i was in that class i met
stephanie um outside of the class and uh
and she had some financial work that she
was doing on her own
so we decided to take the class again a
couple months later together uh while we
were dating ah awesome i thought you're
about to say that y'all met in the fpu
class i was like oh man and then they
work at ramsey
a little bit a little bit over the top
okay so then you get married you finish
up that debt and then you take this job
and come here that's right well actually
we paid off the debt i paid my last
student loan the day before we got
married oh wow so we got to go into
marriage completely debt-free oh that's
neat okay
all right amazing very cool okay so for
you guys i know having three kids i mean
about to have three
you're living life you're doing all this
and the thought of even paying off a
house that feels impossible i was just
talking to a friend actually two days
ago about this and she was like i just
don't even think it's possible
so you did the impossible so what what
is the hardest part
having a young family you guys are young
you're doing this like what was the
thing that you were like oh man this is
just tough this is tough like are we
crazy are we crazy by doing this yeah i
i mean i mentioned that uh we set a plan
when we got here that we were going to
pay it off in five years and making that
decision and commitment um was hard and
an important big step to start with but
throughout the entire journey
just having the discipline to say no
over and over again
if you were to walk into our house today
you'd see a couch with holes all through
it
from dogs and kids jumping on it and
we've had the discipline over the last
four years to say no and you know cover
it up when guests come over and that
sort of thing
in order to be able to have uh this
moment right here yeah that's amazing
absolutely amazing and worth it and
worth it yeah worth it we had a couch
that we covered up when i was a kid but
just because we couldn't get a better
couch
it wasn't cause we had a goal
you guys that's awesome that's just good
that's amazing so how does it feel to
not have a single payment in the world
at 31 years old
unreal i always i keep telling andrew i
don't i don't feel like i should be here
i don't feel like i deserve this
you do
i mean you guys have done it you have
done it you've done the work you've been
diligent
and people are just not they're not
willing to to do the sacrifice but you
guys have been so focused it's it's
incredible absolutely incredible when
younger when young people do it with
little ones running around
and they do that journey i'm just like
golly there's just there's something
about it that i'm like the sacrifice is
so real it's so real and yeah you
probably pinch yourself every day being
like what so how did it feel when you
when you sent in the last payment well
when we went to the bank it was kind of
anticlimactic you can tell they weren't
happy about paying off our mortgage and
so we were like well let's get out of
here we'll go celebrate
i don't know ice cream
george campbell said the same thing when
him and whitney paid theirs off they
were like they walked in and they're
like
and they're like and we're done okay
we're gonna just walk back out yeah but
the idea is yeah yeah that was better
funny and so stephanie uh how big a nerd
is mr analytical andrew
i mean on the nerd spectrum it's
probably like as far as you can go on
dialed in yes yes that's why we hired
him by the way yeah because he that's
what he's supposed to do right
but i mean he's got this dialed in he's
got the spreadsheet he's tracking every
every ounce stephanie's selling herself
short though she's an accountant a cpa
as well
[Music]
[Applause]
good what are y'all gonna do after what
are you doing what's like the next
what's like the big thing what's the fun
thing you're gonna do since you've been
sacrificing for so long yeah so uh get a
couch go to disney
[Music]
we've actually been planning uh a trip
to mississippi of all places uh just to
hang out for a long weekend over uh over
memorial day so just get away for a
couple days get away that's awesome
who are your biggest cheerleaders
oh gosh this team uh here at ramsey has
been incredible um outside of these
walls uh the people that that you run
into they just don't understand the
journey you're on and the sacrifices
that you're making and um and what
you're willing to do for a goal um but
every day here at ramsey i feel
supported
yeah way to go very cool
very cool well we're honored honored to
have you on the team we're so proud of
you
as friends but as team members certainly
and uh wow 31 years old 650 000 paid for
house boom
just like that
i love it so
very very fun you just got to love this
absolutely amazing all right it's andrew
oh no we got the little ones i'm sorry
bring the little ones up the names and
ages
uh so the younger one here is emeline
she's 18 months old
and this is adalyn and she is three
years old okay and who's doing the
handoff here uh that's grandma and
grandpa all right well they're proud of
you i love it very good all right
adeline and emilyn
uh stephanie and andrew andrew is a team
member here for four years 238 000
that's their house they did that in
three years and nine months and 20 days
to be precise and houses work 650
they're 31 years old 100
debt-free baby count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream ready
three two one we're
free
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
wow
i'm uh since baby steps millionaires
came out a lot of our team members are
coming around saying hey we got the
house paid off uh we just added up the
401k and the other stuff and the net
worth just went over a million dollars
and the number of times i'm hearing that
in the last month around the building
here
pretty amazing and um
you know they make you know the folks
here make market rate they make good
money but we're not paying people a
million dollars a year here either so
right they're doing this stuff because
they're they're following the baby steps
and they're truly baby steps
millionaires in the process and so i
suspect andrew and stephanie are there
or very very close at this point that's
very very cool and it's always
encouraging to me where i'm like you
know that took four years in a long four
years i'm sure it felt like but i'm like
that's such a blink i'm like you look
forward and you're like oh my gosh you
know in the next four years what you're
gonna have invested and what you guys
are gonna be able to do as a family and
you just keep going going away i'm like
for a short period of time a short
period of time it's hard but it's so
worth it they're amazing live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 15 1 a
gentle answer turns away wrath but a
harsh word stirs up anger dale carnegie
said don't be afraid of enemies who
attack you be afraid of friends who
flatter you
oh man really wow
pretty fun really
hold on
can we talk about that for a second dale
i took his class when i was in high
school flatter flatter flattery
i know flattery is not true
oh okay it's a you know it's just a
comfortable untrue it's an untrue
compliment really yeah flattery gregory
is in baltimore maryland hi gregory how
are you
uh how you doing dave i'm better than
expected and rachel
um
uh my question for you is well i've got
three really but i know i don't have
much time so i'm gonna talk fast
um i'm i'm caregiver for my 97 year old
mother who lives with me who lives with
me
and she has
an annuity with a well-known christian
organization in which she pays
um yearly five thousand dollars
contributes and she gets about 12 law
over 1200 in dividends i guess it is
and i'm wondering is it
[ __ ] should i get her out of that i'm i
am her uh
power of attorney and i'm wondering
should i get her out of that
um
she's always been a giver
so
and it's reflected in that
um but
i'm just
excuse me i'm sorry that's okay so the
um
so uh
who is the beneficiary on the annuity
i have no idea
okay you need to find that out
and um
uh because i should be who she wants it
to be and that way the money will from
the annuity will pass to that person
upon her
passing away
um yeah you need to make sure that is in
order with her being 97.
so um how's her health
she has memory issues okay
all right um
but you know she still walks and she
still can with help get in the tub and
lost herself and she still eats herself
wow
i would um yeah i'd make sure the
beneficiary is correct on it because
that's who's going to receive the money
from the annuity upon her death
and we want to make sure that that is
set up correct and as the power of
attorney you can do that you can take
care of that and if it's not set
properly if it's set to someone that she
wouldn't want it to go to now and she
just forgot to change it then you can
jump in there and get it changed to set
it up for something else i'm probably
not going to cash it out at her age
because she's probably going to have
some penalties or something else i would
try to figure out a way to stop adding
to it
yes you know that's what
that's my dilemma yeah
trying to find out what you know you
have to stop if you have to cash it out
to stop adding to it and there's not any
penalties
and you just set the money in a bank
account that's fine
because we're probably not investing
long term when we're 97 agreed
right
that's true
statistically so yeah number one make
sure the beneficiary is right then
number two you need to find out you know
what the implications are of closing it
down and make sure there's not a big
bunch of penalties or something
and you know so if she dies what happens
and if she lives and you take it out
what happens these are the two things
you need to get dug into exactly what
the details are you have the right to do
all of that as her power of attorney and
you should immediately and then that'll
help you make the decision as to what to
do if you need some
investment advice you can sit down one
of our smartvestor pros they might be
able to help you
uh
comb through this if you go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on smart
vester they might be able to help you
analyze the information and decide what
to do because i can't tell from what
you're describing exactly who or what
she's gotten into here
um but i do know that an annuity always
has a beneficiary on it like a life
insurance policy does and so the money
will pass directly to that person and
that might be the easiest way to cash it
in is for her when she passes away
and so um
you know that's what i would look at
jared is in florida hi jared welcome to
the ramsay show
hey guys can you hear me okay sure
what's up
so
i had a 2017 jeep it was pretty nice it
had bells and whistles and stuff but my
move to make myself debt-free was to
trade it in for an 07 mustang
it's uh
it's it's just the car you know it's not
as crazy high-tech as my old one was
um
and i don't know i'm just trying to
justify to myself that i did the right
thing
it was a 300 a month payment so
you know i'm debt free now
what do you make
about 50 a year take home what's mustang
worth
i haven't looked that up i'd assume
around
actually i did a while ago it's about
three and a half or four thousand
okay all right
and uh well i mean if you save up money
and move up a little bit in car that's
fine
uh how old are you
i'm 26 years old i'm an or nurse okay
cool
that's good news that you've got a great
career and you can add hours whenever
you want to and uh do a lot of different
things here to be able to um
you know hit some financial goals now
you're debt free that's a good thing yes
you did the right thing
but uh there's nothing wrong with owning
a car that you like and so it's you know
saving up and moving up in that as long
as it's no more than half your annual
income and invested in things that are
going down in value then that's fine but
what you've got some margin there to
move up at this point i mean if you
added ten thousand dollars cash to this
and moved up to a fifteen thousand
dollar car it'd probably be a completely
different vehicle right
yeah absolutely um i'd be willing to
drive this car for basically until the
wheels fall off i'm not a huge car guy
but
i i would be able to move up in a while
if i was able to you know save and do it
the right way yeah but another thing for
me is i just started investing into my
company's roth 401k good
i did the low-cap mid cap high cap and
international
and
i i picked one from each one mutual fund
of each and it seems like it's been
going down for the last month or so i
shouldn't worry i should keep my head on
it right correct
correct the market's been going down
yeah so you're just riding the market
mine went down too by the way
all right good night yeah so we're just
you know we're not we're not i i don't i
don't track stuff on a monthly basis i
look at it about once a year and i
generally check to see if my funds are
doing
a little better or about what the market
is doing and if they are then i just
leave them alone
but you know we're just we're here to
ride the long long term and over the
long term is where you make money in a
good mutual fund
good deal hey man thanks for the call we
appreciate you joining us i know it can
be a little distressing especially in
the times we've been in of just like
sometimes the market was nuts and then
it's like and then this then i mean it's
just it's all over the place and so yeah
i mean i do the same as you i'm like i
don't even look at it
once a year take a glance make sure
everything's good and looking good but
you'd stress yourself out or i would
looking at everything every little thing
i'm like
it is it's normal though human nature
when you very first start investing you
want to check on it you want to see
what's done let's see what's doing it
see what it's doing and you first start
investing and then it goes down
that's like what yeah is that how this
works you know that's all he's saying
and that's a that's a normal thing and
um
you know i appreciate you asking about
it because it's a normal human emotion
to look at that but you didn't invest
for one month you invested for
uh
you know 30 30 years
when you bought one into your 401k
you're 26. so 40 years you're 66 years
old that's when that money's going to
sell all you got to worry about is is it
going to be down when you're 66 and the
likelihood of that is almost zero yeah
yeah
zero percent chance you're gonna have
it's gonna be down by the time you're 66
so you're gonna be okay
and uh that that's the play and nobody
gets hurt on a roller coaster except
those that jump off in the middle of the
ride so right right
and uh you're investing when it's up and
you're investing this down and you're
investing when it's up and you're
investing when it's down and you just
keep going folks
and uh you let your intellect overpower
your emotions
and then you keep with it rachel cruz
good show today yes thanks so much so
fun thanks to james to ben and to kelly
zach in the booth
taking care of business in there
that puts the ramsey show in the books
we will be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free screen live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you